[Musique]
il faut marcher les attentes à faire il
faut rouler m'acharner s'en faut tourner
bean est relatée dans le garage et
quatre ans après le succès des
magnifiques chansons de paloma même si
le public en redemande de vos chansons
vous revenez avec un album instrumental
etes-vous en chicane avec les avec les
textes avec les chansons une optique
tout
[Musique]
non je suis surtout en accord et en
synchro ce que je veux faire je vais
toujours où la l'énergie m'amène donc
l'album instrumental m'appelait depuis
quelques années d'ailleurs quand j'ai
toujours quelques instrumental sur mes
albums depuis rêver mieux vous êtes
amusé là dessus vous jouer la guitare de
la base du banjo saxophone piano avec le
temps on dirait que vous prenez plaisir
à travailler sur ce que je me trompe
oui ben c'est moins compliqué pour moi
de travailler ce n'est pas beaucoup de
difficultés m'expliquer ce que je veux
donc donc je vais je sais plus il n'ya
pas d'interférence en fait c'est alors
si je veux faire une ligne de basse le
ch est exactement ce que je veux il a
maintenant alors je te jure que
l'expérience que j'ai je capable de
faire ce que j'ai en tête plutôt que de
l'expliquer que donc c'est pas vraiment
voulu
[Musique]
votre album s'intitule travelling pas
pour le voyage mais pour la rue pour le
mouvement caméra daniel bélanger est un
cinéphile et qu'il se nourrit de films
poursuit
non mais j'ai l'impression que j'ai vu
tellement de films une époque de ma vie
où je restais dans le west island qui je
ne prends des cours à montréal au centre
macler conception puis des fois j'allais
beaucoup
j'aurais dû y aller et j'allais voir
jaleo parise et le cinéma parisien 70
rue j'allais voir deux films défilé j'ai
fait ça pendant
très très très longtemps halifax n é co
ou le cinéma et j'étais très donc après
ça il ya eu moins de cinéma mais j'ai
l'impression que ma banque une influence
a été fait dans cette période là et
puisqu un imperméable donc légalement
film sur truc 6 milliards
similaire de 5 6 milliards si beaucoup
ces derniers mois vous avez ressusciter
le bonhomme à lui m c'est le blâme à lui
mettre de l'album rêver mieux qui a à
peu près 20 ans ouais j'ai écouté la
chanson dans un strip league c3 dans
d'aussi milliards de solitude 6
milliards ça fait beaucoup
on dirait que c'est une chanson que j'ai
écrite pour aujourd'hui
meyer 20 ans oui mais trop bien chanceux
oui mais les ondes on peut on peut
enlever des chansons d'un contexte le
métallo puis si on était droit sur son x
canton le canton le fait la chanson ça
se peut que ce soit praticable
c'est ce qu'on souhaite en fait quand on
écrit d'être un peu durable et puisque
si gentiment
dj peut-être que nos chansons plus
puisse se lire autrement dans un autre
et ça c'est la magie du hasard on quand
j'écris dans un spoutnik je me suis pas
dit on dans la pandémie 2020 sont
extraordinaires cette chanson là dans le
sens sa brioche aux mondiaux je vais
avoir l'air de 20 mais notre à la il ya
beaucoup de gens qui nous écoutent en ce
moment qu'ils sont très attachés à cet
album rêver oui lettres ou encore je
suis beaucoup mes trois premiers albums
ont changé ma vie à chaque fois qu'ils
sont sortis et rêver mieux je trouve
subtile de je la relis je gagnais rêver
mieux c'est moi qui le fuit le fait les
gens sont attachés
il faut aussi je me suis souvenu que
rêver mieux sorti cinq semaines après le
11 septembre 2001
ce qui fait que ça aussi marqué beaucoup
le un album aussi très empathique très
ouvert sur l'impression que les gens
sont tout aussi peut-être dans cet état
d'esprit là d'un sécurité mondiale
[Musique]
chaque sortie d'album de l'année
bélanger est un événement musical ya
même des comptes sur votre site internet
le d'or en euros pour suivre la sortie
d'album comment vous vivez cette forme
de pression
il ya toujours une pression
effectivement il ya une pression donc je
suis sur l'adrénaline depuis que le
décompte est commencé
donc sachant aux misères de sommeil ça
change mon sommeil et pourtant tout est
relax c'est un album que j'aime les gens
l'attendent avec plaisir pas
l'agressivité
je devrais être l'acteur est en train de
fumer une cigarette et mais non il ya un
on s'expose donc c'est une période où on
s'expose pour la première fois avec de
l'inconnu les gens apprennent à à
rencontrer les gens qui aiment autres
avaient rencontré le nouvel album
[Musique]
devrait être relax méchant quand même
une pression pression de
la pression de la nouveauté le support
dans l'énergie quel plaisir merci
beaucoup merci à vous